dany langue merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors pour bien
comprendre très concrètement les 500
milliards nécessaires à l'europe pour se
remettre de la crise
qu'est-ce qu'ils doivent renflouer alors
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire on se
trouve dans une situation quand même
assez original où on a demandé à un
certain nombre de commerces et
d'industries de fermer leurs portes
pendant plusieurs mois et donc il
s'agira de faire redémarrer
tous ces secteurs qui ont été à l'arrêt
500 milliards ça me paraît un strict
minimum
moi je suis pas forcément très rassurés
par le fait que ça passe par le
mécanisme européen de stabilité
pourquoi justement où ce mécanisme
européen de stabilité veut aller
chercher cet argent qui financerait est
ce que c'est une bonne idée selon vous
il faut au minimum 500 milliards parce
que une fois de plus son ami l'économie
à l'arrêt et la pire des réactions ce
serait maintenant de freiner sur la
dépense alors qu'on est tout en bas du
cycle c'est c'est le moment où on a
besoin de relancer la dépense et en
particulier de relancer la dépense pour
toutes les industries qui ont été à
l'arrêt pendant des mois tout en faisant
attention aux industries qui sont en
charge sauf celles qui ont continué de
fonctionner pendant le confinement et en
particulier certaines industries
alimentaires etc
donc c'est 500 milliards sont plus que
nécessaires à mon avis il faudrait même
aller plus loin
où est ce qu'on va les chercher je ne
sais pas encore ce sera les sept fois
aux dirigeants européens de décider
c'est un parent est même relativement un
peu par rapport à la hauteur de l'enjeu
alors 500 milliards qui s'ajoute à
d'autres en souvient le 9 avril les
ministres des finances de l'union
européenne avaient déjà convenu d'un
plan de soutien de 500 milliards d'euros
après d'ailleurs des semaines de
querelles alors est ce que ces nouveaux
500 milliards nécessaires est ce qu'ils
peuvent à nouveau révélé des divisions
selon vous avez très probablement on a
de toute façon sein de la zone euro
au sein du conseil européen qui qui est
l'ensemble des chefs d'état gouvernement
on a des visions extrêmement différente
des choses et en particulier les pays du
nord traite les pays du fils de cigales
alors qu'il ferait mieux de faire le
ménage devant chez eux
c'est souvent les pays qui travaillent
le moins en terme de nombre de travail
en nombre d'heures de travail par
semaine comme les pays bas et qui compte
ou sur leurs exportations qui vont
donner des leçons b du sud alors qu'ils
sont très mal placés pour le faire
donc effectivement il y aura des
divergences importantes j'espère
simplement que on ne va pas faire les
mêmes erreurs qu'en 2008 c'est à dire
d'abord en plan de relance et puis
ensuite des infor plan d'austérité qui
finirait de nous achever dans un
contexte où la dette privée et à des
niveaux extrêmement inquiétant est-ce
que cet argent il aurait pu arriver plus
tôt parce qu'on a vu chaque chaque pays
finalement gérer le problème à sa
manière est ce que ça aurait dû être
actives et davantage en amont selon vous
ça dépend des secteurs ça dépend des
pays il paraît clair que ça ne sert à
rien de d'injecter de l'argent
d'injecter de la dépense publique ou
d'injecter du pouvoir d'achat aux
consommateurs au moment même du
confinement
sauf peut-être vers les hôpitaux vers
les secteurs qui en avaient absolument
besoin rapidement
donc à mon avis il aurait fallu beaucoup
plus tôt mettre des sommes sur la table
sans attente que l'épidémie soit aussi
étendue est donc allé acheter des max
des vaccins allaient acheter des masques
des mois de janvier en particulier comme
l'a fait l'allemagne 1 de ce point de
vue là ils ont bien géré la crise ils
ont acheté les vaccins avant tout le
monde donc il fallait mettre cet argent
sur la table en partie avant et en
particulier pour soutenir le système de
santé qui était qui quand même délabrée
dans un certain nombre de pays mais pour
les autres secteurs ça ne servait à rien
ça sert à rien d'injecter des liquidités
dans l'économie
quand un certain nombre de secteurs sont
à l'arrêt et à mon avis il va falloir
faire un effort durable parce que là il
faut assurer le redis
sur fond de secteur il faudra surtout
songer à ce que la reprise soit durable
et une reprise durable
ça passe avant tout par la prise au
sérieux de la transition écologique
si on se retrouve dans cette situation
sanitaire délabré et désastreux c'est
aussi à cause d'un vent de
l'organisation libérale et aussi à cause
du délabrement du système de santé des
systèmes de santé dans qu'on a à travers
le mans donc il faut des sommes
conséquentes pour aller leur la
transition écologique il va falloir
investir massivement pour aller vers une
relocalisation des insultes des
industries donc tout ça demande des
milliards
et effectivement je ne suis pas certain
que 500 milliards suffiront il aurait
fallu commencer avant mais il aurait
fallu commencer par l'hôpital
ensuite on reviendra au secteur privé en
particulier aux entreprises qui sont
très endettés merci beaucoup
dany lang d'avoir partagé votre analyse
rappelle que vous êtes économiste et
maître de conférences à l'université
paris xiii
merci